النظره التشاؤميه للاقتصاد العالمي حملتها
صدمات العام 20 22 سلسه ازمات ناقضت
توقعات السابقه بان 20 22 سيكون عاما من
الازدهار الارتفاع الحاد في الاسعار زياده
معدلات الفائده الاحترار المناخي ازمه
الطاقه الخانقه والحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا كلها ازمات تنذر بعام قاتم في 20
المؤرخ ادم توز اطلق على 20 22 تعبيرا
يلخص ما حدث عام متعدد الازمات متحدثا عن
صدمات متباينه تتفاعل معا لتجعل الوضع
العام في غايه الصعوبه صدمات بدات وتزايدت
منذ بدايه القرن مع الازمه الماليه عام
2008 وازمه ديون السياديه
وازمه الطاقه لم يشهد وضع بهذا القدر من
التعقيد منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وفقراء مشهد اكده بن رئيس قسم تحليل
الاقتصاد الكلي في اقصر ايكونوميكس في
مقابله مع العربيه اوضح فيها اسباب النظر
التشاؤميه للاقتصاد العالمي
توقعاتنا في اكسفورد ايكونوميكس اسوا من
الاراء السائده بشان نمو الاقتصاد العالمي
السنه القادمه نحن نتوقع ضعفا اكبر وركودا
اسود من توقعات الاخرين لكن اذا نظرنا الى
التجارب التاريخيه هذا الركود سيكون
محدودا وسيكون اصغر من متوسط الفترات
السابقه في التاريخ
فبعد سنوات من التضخم الضعيف او حتى
المستقر الا ان الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا والارتفاع الحاد في اسعار الطاقه
بدل الوضع سجل تضخم مستويات غير مسبوقه
منذ سبعينات والثمانينات دافعا ملايين
العائلات في الدول الناميه الى الفقر
ومهددا الاسر في الدول الفقيره بمزيد من
البؤس غير انه بدا يتباطا الى 10% في
منطقه اليورو في نوفمبر وسته في المئه في
الولايات المتحده في اكتوبر ويمكن ان
يتراجع التضخم في الدول المتطوره والناشئه
الكبرى من مجموعه العشرين في 20 23
24 بحسب منظمه التعاون والتنميه في
الميدان الاقتصادي الا ان رئيس قسم تحليل
الاقتصاد الكلي في اوكسفورد ايكونوميكس
لديه راي اخر
[موسيقى]
من العوامل
الذي يضغط على استهلاك الاسر والدخل
الحقيقي ويؤدي الى تقليل الانفاق اضافه
الى سياسات تشديد الفائده التي شاهدناها
على مدار السنه وهذا يحتاج وقتا ليتجسد في
الاقتصاد بشكل حقيقي